[Music]
[Applause]
let's make way for uh sports illustrated
chris mannix senior nba writer for
sports illustrated um
your initial reaction mannix after the
uh westbrook trade
a little surprised so in the last few
days
really weeks the lakers have basically
dangled the the
kyle kuzma kentavious caldwell pope
package to
uh almost every team that's out there
and
they didn't have a lot of takers but in
the last two or three days
there was some traction with sacramento
on
a buddy heel trade and if you look at
that trade
it makes sense i mean healed heals one
of those guys
that yeah you you kind of look at him as
empty calories in a way never been on a
winning team
but the numbers are what they are he's
been close to or above 40
from three in each of the last four
seasons and
when you look at what the lakers need
perimeter shooting is at the top of that
list
instead to pivot and to basically
deliver that exact same package you were
going to send sacramento for healed
to washington for westbrook is puzzling
and i just you know did
i carpet bombed kind of every assistant
coach that i know with text and asked
them
you know what do they think and and
every one of them said
it doesn't make a lot of sense if you're
lebron james what you're looking for
is a floor spacer and a secondary
playmaker
russ is not a floor spacer and is a
primary playback somebody we know
succeeds with the ball in his hands so
why did they do it
it's still hard to i i haven't talked to
anybody in l.a
since the deal got done last night dan
so i don't i don't know but
there's obviously a strong relationship
between lebron
and russell westbrook um i wonder what
voice lebron
had in all this uh
i don't i can't i can explain it with
dan like you know russ
you you know me i i've always been a
pretty strong defender of russell
westbrook i
i firmly believe that this triple double
mark he's been putting up over the years
is is impressive but for that team
it doesn't make a lot of basketball
sense i love the buddy healed
possibility because
that's what they needed uh like who's
who's the point guard on this team now
is
well that's that's the thing because you
know the last two years
under frank vogel it was a priority
for vogel to say lebron you are now the
point guard we're going to transition
you
to being the primary playmaker russ is
not
like damien lillard who you can play off
the ball when cj mccollum
is operating as point guard he's someone
that needs the ball in his hands
and needs to play downhill in order to
be successful i mean
in like a perfect world you'd say russ
you're the sixth man
and you come off the bench and you be
that instant offense guy to carve up
second units
but we both know that's not going to
happen so russ
a.d lebron surrounded by
taylonhorn tucker and i i don't know
caruso maybe in that front court you're
obviously gonna have to play another big
because we know a.d doesn't want to be a
five
for most of his uh his playing time so
i guess you're talking about marc gasol
who's got a contract for next year
it just seems if you're a team looking
at the lakers how to defend them
you're going to shrink the floor a lot
and make them beat you from three-point
yeah i know
plus russ has won speed and can lebron
play at that speed
are they best at that speed i i it's
puzzling well they they do
they you know they do want to play up
tempo like that's something that's been
a staple of of what at least how frank
vogel wants to play
ideally so lebron at 37 you're gonna be
no i mean maybe it's a case where
lebron's not you know lebron's not
filling the lane anymore like you know
maybe it's the case where russ just kind
of
initiates a lot of the the up tempo
offense and
they see if they can get easy buckets
that way dan honestly
i'm grasping at straws a little bit here
because
you know defenses are smart defensive
coaches are smart
they're going to figure out how to
shrink the floor
and make west i mean look dan you go
back to the bubble playoffs i remember
watching in the bubble lakers against
rockets
i mean one of the priorities
for the lakers defensively was to take
the ball out of james harden's hands and
make russ shoot
and he had some good moments but
how how they played against russ is how
teams are now going to start playing
against them
whenever i need a good laugh i always
look at what the 76ers are asking for
ben
simmons and uh i don't know what the
strategy is unless it's
hey we're gonna ask for all of this
knowing that we'll take
half of this but at some point
the team stopped calling because it just
seems so preposterous what they ask
from the warriors or what they ask from
the spurs it's crazy
yeah but i think it's really smart
because if you're not highly motivated
to move ben simmons
which the sixers don't need to be he's
under contract for four more years
yes i think both sides agree that a
divorce
is probably in the best interest of
everyone but they don't need to do it
right now they're on the position that
new orleans was in a couple of years ago
where they had to move anthony davis
in order to get something back in return
they can be patient with this so why not
ask for the moon and hope that some gm
out there is
crazy enough to give it to them like if
i
i've said this to you before the sixers
are going to be watching portland
everybody is
and if you're the sixers why not see if
there's a godfather
offer out there right now and if there's
not let's just wait
maybe that means bringing ben simmons to
training camp
in in september october and then see
what happens with the trailblazers
because
if you just be patient you could wind up
with
some combination of either damien
lillard or
cj mccollum and that's going to make
your team significantly better so i
i think daryl mori is playing this
perfectly right now
ask for the biggest possible trade
package and see if somebody is crazy
enough out there to give it to you
well you've devalued him the 76ers have
devalued him but then they
over value him yeah but how do they
devalue him
because they're shopping him well yeah
but everybody it's like it's
you know it's like no you know no gm is
picking up their phone going wow you're
really going to deal ben simmons like
everybody knows it like it
everybody can see how this team his
stock has never been
lower chris it's never been lower but
i do think the more time passes from
that
playoff performance you're going to
remember the positives more than the
negatives
and there are a lot of positives with
ben simmons so the worst thing
philadelphia can do
is you know make a deal that
even one that resembles the james harden
deal i mean the rockets didn't get a lot
in in the james harden deal you want
something that more resembles
like paul george but but harden was
devalued because he was out of shape and
he wanted out of town
like ben simmons is in shape he didn't
want out of town
and he's not a contract he he is well
yeah
harden hard you needed to deal because
hardin yes was
you know doing his best george costanza
there at the end of his time
but they want to harden hall and ben
simmons isn't james harden
well they want more than a hard and hall
that's the whole thing like the hardin
hall isn't very good like you look back
at that deal
what did they get for that i mean unless
the nets implode in the way the nets
imploded 10 years ago
um that's not going to be a very good
haul of drafts they want the paul george
hall they want something
that closely resembles that and honestly
dan i think they might be able to get it
at some point
like it might be in their best interest
to rehabilitate
ben simmons next season isn't it like if
you can just remind
people how good this guy is like a year
so removed
from being what all nba second team
all-star a perennial all-star
with a lot of positives maybe you remind
people of that maybe that stock goes
higher
i do think he needs to sort of disappear
from
an elite playoff team i think he he
needs to
hit a reset button so he can kind of
play a game without everybody analyzing
everything he does i think
well i i think more than anything he
needs to
not that not that i buy into like
players that
post stuff on instagram of them working
on stuff i think that's a little
that's the new i don't know what that is
that's the new goofy thing that players
do
but i i haven't heard much about
you know all these this work ben simmons
is doing on his shot and it's almost
august
like i'm just that's what we heard i've
worked on my
shot more this summer than ben simmons
has i can guarantee that and my shot is
already very good yeah well i've seen
your shot yes i'm aware it's uh
it's your strength but i i just i hope
ben simmons is doing some things
because training camp is a month and a
half two months away
and are we still we'll be right back to
where we started
with ben because that would be a
nightmare for the sixers it's always
great to talk to you chris
dan um big deal last night was
ricky rubio has a new team yeah i think
that's his fifth team
i think it's more than five but no no is
it no all-star teams
well i mean if if the cavaliers make the
playoffs
this year um it's not gonna be because
of evan mobley
it's not gonna be because of com because
of colin sexton it's gonna because
the reunion between ricky rubio and
kevin love propelled them
into the postseason it was three years
ago today
we gave you a buzz cut
we changed your life with the haircut we
gave you and improved your social
game dramatically this
there's really nothing that can do that
damn i don't social game is
pretty low these days i got to tell you
ricky rubio
ricky rubio is something you're the
people ricky rubio is a real thing
you're the ricky rubio of dating
a lot of hype not a lot of production no
no real all-star appearances no loyalty
that's team i have loyalty i will
ricky's loyal he just keeps getting
dumped like
like like you do correct have a great
weekend
you too dan say bye